toute l'actualité du continent africain
c'est maintenant sur france 24 à vis de
vous retrouver dans votre journal de
l'afrique aujourd'hui la rdc durci le
ton face à la monusco après plus d'une
semaine de contestation le porte-parole
de la mission de l'onu est soumis de
quitter le territoire en cause des
propos sur rfi notre confrère passion ni
gaudi nous expliquent
les producteurs de cacao ivoirien en
grève pour la deuxième fois de l'année
leur revendication un prix plus juste le
pays est le premier producteur mondial
sécheresse qu'ovide et guerre en ukraine
combo perdant pour les prix au kenya la
défense du pouvoir d'achat un thème
phare à six jours de la présidentielle
l'avenir de la monusco en rd congo
s'assombrit les autorités demandent
désormais à son porte-parole de quitter
le pays cela fait une semaine que dans
l'est la mission des nations unies est
conspué dans la rue à coup de
manifestations meurtrières au moins 30
personnes sont décédées elle est accusée
de ne pas remplir pleinement son rôle de
protection patients ligot dit vous êtes
le correspondant de rfi radio france
internationale à kinshasa bonjour un
épisode de plus dans ce climat de
défiance qui s'est installé entre la
monusco et la population pour ce qui est
de cette demande d'expulsion tout est
partie de propos jugés indélicats
et plus à contre
pied
par dessus on rappelle la chaîne
iii puisque dernier d'une pluie cet
équipement depuis huit siècles ticket
notamment en termes de capacité litière
à m'emporter de métier militaire
interdite hier des précisions sur
d'autres il faut rappeler que la marche
est un marcheur si l'année ce qui est à
des balades dans les deux cas liés à
l'époque 6,83
abattu alors qu'il était condamné par
chiffrement des contacts en 3d
et on est passé par la ji efficacité sur
d'autres fronts
la batterie rentre là
de son côté la mission
attention contient
patients ligot dit merci vous êtes le
correspondant de rfi à kinshasa suspense
au sénégal décompte des voix toujours en
cours après les législatives de dimanche
les premiers résultats sont tombés au
niveau départemental rien de déterminant
donc pouvoir et opposition s'arroge la
victoire 165 postes de députés sont en
jeu
les cacaoculteurs de côte d'ivoire
veulent leur part du gâteau où ils ont
entamé une grève illimitée il revendique
un prix de l'or brun raisonnable et
décembre à abidjan en bijoux dominion
les planteurs de cacao se sont
marginalisées dont les prises de
décision il reproche au gouvernement
ivoirien de ne pas prendre en compte
leurs revendications ils souhaitent une
amélioration de leurs conditions de vie
à cela s'ajoute une mise à l'écart dans
l'établissement de la norme cacao
durable cette arme a initié par an
l'union européenne exige que
l'exploitation du cacao se fasse dans le
respect de certaines règles écologiques
liées à la déforestation
le hic c'est que les producteurs n'ont
même pas été associés aujourd'hui ils
sont nombreux les producteurs qui ne
savent même pas ce que contient cette
note elle n'a pas fait l'objet de deux
du real avant d'être exposée aux
producteurs afin qu'ils aient un sens
c'est un élément qui les tiennent à que
le mot d'ordre de grève va se
matérialiser par des sittings dont les
différentes délégations régionales du
conseil café-cacao l'arrêt des ventes de
fèves et l'occupation du terrain nous
sommes allés à la rencontre des notes
dia planteurs à dabou ville située à 43
km d'abidjan selon lui il faut respecter
les prix bord champ qui sont les prix
d'achat de base institué par les tailles
variant ce qui n'est toujours pas le cas
sa note nul nous comptons beaucoup de
problèmes parce que nous n'avons pas
assez de moyens pour pouvoir entraîner
les seins parce que le pack on n'est pas
payé à un prix raisonnable le prix du
cacao par kilogramme fixée à 8 125
francs cfa n'est jamais respectée selon
les planteurs ils dénoncent des
intermédiaires qui achètent le cacao à
vil prix pour le revendre plus cher pour
l'instant la durée de la grève est
illimitée
blé gaz pétrole ce n'est un secret pour
personne la guerre en ukraine fait
flamber le coût des matières premières
et le niger n'échappe pas à la règle à
la pompe il faudra désormais payer plus
d'un euro le litre de gasoil problème
les nigériens vivent en moyenne avec
moins de deux euros par jour reportage
d'harold jarre
de 538 à 668 francs cfa depuis le début
de la semaine le gasoil nigérien est
vendu à plus d'un euro le litre une
gageure pour la plupart des habitants de
la capitale niamey si le salaire moyen
ici au niger est évalué autour de 50
euros et bien beaucoup d'habitants
survivent avec des moyens et des revenus
encore plus faible que cela cette
augmentation du prix du gasoil va
renforcer les problèmes liés à
l'enclavement du territoire un nigérien
nous avons pu rencontrer plusieurs
transporteurs de marchandises blue qui
aux abords de la ville qui n'avaient pas
les moyens de payer le carburant
nécessaire pour reprendre leur trajet
là il faut aller chez un peu juste une
station mais sans parler par l'apport
plus que transportait le chauffeur était
dans le pré liste 538 situera pas
habitués est adoré à l'est du mans voilà
le lundi le prêt à changer quand je
connais le prix du gasoil deuxième pays
mais subitement comme ça ça fait que ça
amène un peu l'épreuve entre le
chauffeur et le propriétaire ça joue sur
nous
sur les propriétés est su le
client a aussi un impact direct sur les
consommateurs de tous les secteurs car
les convois ralenti voire annuler
contribuer à l'augmentation des prix des
produits déjà au niger le gouvernement
nigérien explique la montée du prix du
gasoil sur son sol par la guerre en
ukraine mais aussi par la remontée du
prix du baril de pétrole brut il y a
deux mois environ le gouvernement
nigérien avait déjà été contraint de
suspendre plusieurs type d'importations
à cause d'une forte pénurie de gasoil
mais à ce moment là avait réussi à
maintenir les prix à la pompe stable et
des prix à la pompe qui augmente aussi
au kenya dans le pays l'inflation a
bondi en juillet 8,3 pour cent
la hausse du coût de la vie est une
préoccupation majeure des kenyans la
présidentielle c'est le 9 août et les
candidats l'ont bien compris ils
multiplient les annonces reportage
france24 signé viviane lembert à
sébastien roduit
dans ce magasin de kibera un bidonville
de nairobi les prix ont doublé au cours
des deux dernières années là deux
paquets de farine et aussi un peu de
sucre 1
pour mille xining soit un peu moins de 9
euros morphine a pu acheter 4 kg de
farine de maïs un litre d'huile et un
kilo de sucre à peine de quoi nourrir
une famille de 4 pendant une semaine il
faut écouter by reiss mais avant je
pouvais acheter du riz de la farine de
l'huile des allumettes des mouchoirs
mais ce n'est plus possible je ne peux
plus aller dans un magasin et dépenser
1000 schilling comme ça je dois prévoir
ce que je veux je dois par exemple
sauter le déjeuner pour dépenser un
minimum tous
selon la banque mondiale 33% des kenyans
vivent avec moins de 57 euros par mois
en campagne tous les candidats
promettent d'augmenter le pouvoir
d'achat devenue la principale
préoccupation de la population à
l'approché du scrutin engage les de
toute évidence les leaders politiques
doivent s'exprimer sur cette crise parce
que si cela n'est pas réglé ça peut
créer un soulèvement populaire comme
c'est arrivé dans d'autres pays
le kenya qui a pourtant l'une des
économies les plus solides du continent
a atteint une inflation de près de 8%
son niveau le plus élevé depuis cinq ans
est un cochon ambiance pareille c'est le
résultat de plusieurs choses néfastes
qui se mélangent et on en arrive au
point où il n'y a pas de nourriture
c'est notre gouvernement n'a plus
d'argent et donc les effets positifs du
fonds d'urgence se font vraiment
attendre d'autant plus que 60% du budget
est utilisé pour la tête
al'approche de l'élection les kenyans
attendent de vraies propositions de
sortie de crise le gouvernement vient
d'annoncer qu'il financerait une partie
du coût de la farine cette aide sera
supprimée mi août juste après le vote
face à cette hausse mondiale des prix de
l'énergie de jeunes entrepreneurs
tunisiens essaye de s'adapter ils ont
trouvé des plans b écolo lilia blaise et
aime dit lily les ont rencontrés
reportage
dans sa ferme en périphérie de tunis
yacine 34 ans et fondateur de la
start-up bio git ne cultive pas les
oliviers pour faire de l'huile d'olive
comme beaucoup d'agriculteurs tunisien
il en récupère les déchets ce sont les
beiges des déchets obtenu après
l'extraction double cd sheila sont
composés de la pub les grignan et ça
représente presque les 40% de l'olive
obtenus au niveau de will ris avec ce
mélange qu il compresse dans une machine
créée par ses soins yacine fabrique des
bûchers de combustible du aucun liant
chimiques et aucun additif c'était 100%
bio il doit ensuite les faire sécher au
soleil pendant 30 jours pour réduire
l'humidité un long processus qui limite
pour le moment sa capacité de production
mais la demande pour ce substitut de
bois et de plus en plus importante à
cause de la guerre en ukraine et le co
et l'augmentation du fou du combustible
donc on a eu beaucoup de contacts un
kilo de bûchettes remplace 3 kg de bois
et émet moins de co2 ce restaurateur a
été séduit et fait partie de la
quarantaine de clients que compte yacine
c'est propre c'est bio ça donne un goût
spécial la pizza face à l'augmentation
mondiale du coût de l'énergie les
créateurs de la start-up what now sont
allés directement à la source avec un
compteur intelligent qui permet de
réduire de 10 à 30% la consommation
d'électricité dans les usines l'idée en
l'occurrence ici c'est vraiment de
suivre précisément donc la consommation
donc en temps réel des différentes des
différents appareils électriques via une
application qui reçoit les données des
compteurs il peut tout contrôler à
distance détecté une coupure de courant
ou une surconsommation donc ici c'est la
consommation effectivement journalière
en kilowattheures effectivement c'est
beaucoup plus motivant pour un client
leur dire qu'on va vous aider à réduire
vos coûts et ça va avoir un impact sur
sur votre empreinte carbone réduire son
empreinte carbone est primordial pour
ces entrepreneurs c'est l'un des
objectifs de l'onu de développement
durable contre la dégradation de
l'environnement
un grand ouf de soulagement pour les
éleveurs de bétail au burundi après
trois mois d'interdiction l'abattage a
pu reprendre ils avaient été
interrompues en avril dernier après
l'apparition de la fièvre de la vallée
du rift une maladie souvent mortelle
pour les bovins un coup dur donc pour ce
pays essentiellement tournée vers
l'agriculture et l'élevage
et moi c'est pourquoi nous sommes fiers
de voir les vaches à l'abattoir nous
remercions vraiment les autorités qui
ont pris cette décision qui nous soulage
et les burundais mme la viande
pour quatre noms c'est la joie on sait
comment allons nous envoyer nos enfants
à l'école on n'avait pas de solution
notre vie quotidienne se compliquer de
jour en jour
c'était difficile de changer de métier
merci de votre fidélité au journal de
l'afrique l'actualité du continent c'est
à retrouver aussi sur france 24 points
comme mais nos réseaux sociaux d'autres
informations internationales c'est dans
quelques minutes reste avec nous sur
france 24
[Musique]